[Musik]
eine riesige schwanzflosse gewaltige
kiemen und massenhaft muskeln gewalt in
einem fünf meter langen körper forscher
haben vor der küste nova scotia es einen
mega high entdeckt die
non-profit-organisation search begibt
sich seit jahren auf die suche nach
haien um sie mit sendern zu markieren
und wichtige daten zu sammeln
die 39 der expedition führte in die
rauen gewässer vor der küste kanadas
genau hier trafen sie auf die xxl
version des weißen hais das riesige
weibchen ist gut fünf meter lang und
über 1600 kilo schwer
besonders außergewöhnlich ihr alter von
50 jahren während männliche weiße haie
an die 70 jahre alt werden können
erreichen weibchen meist nur ein alter
von etwa 40
passenderweise haben die forscher sina
gummi genannt großmutter in der sprache
des in nova scotia ansässigen
indianerstammes mit seinen 50 jahren hat
der mega high rund 15 fortpflanzungs
zirkel hinter sich juni könnte also bis
zu 100 kinder und zahlreiche enkel haben
nach ein paar harmlosen untersuchungen
und blutenden haben für die forschung
wurde die alte riesen dame dann wieder
ins meer entlassen dass sie seit einem
halben jahrhundert durchkreuzt
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren